you mentioned the kuiper belt what's the
oor cloud
if you look at the neptune orbit as uh
one then the kuiper bell is like 1.3 out
there
and then we get farther and farther into
the darkness what
so okay you've got the kind of main
kuiper belt which is about
say 1.3 1.5
then you have something called the
scattered disc
which is kind of an extension of the
kuiper belt it's a bunch of these
long uh very elliptical orbits that
hug the orbit of neptune but come out
very far
so that the scattered disc um
with the current senses like the some of
the
longest orbits we know of
um have a
semi-major axis so half the orbit length
roughly speaking of about a thousand
thousand times the distance between
the earth and the sun wow now if you
keep moving out
okay eventually once you're at sort of
you know
ten thousand to a hundred thousand
roughly that's where the oort cloud is
now the oort cloud is a distinct
population
of icy bodies and it's distinct from the
kuiper belt it's in fact it's so
expansive
that it ends roughly halfway between
us and the next star it's its edge is
just
dictated by to what extent does the
solar gravity reach
solar gravity reaches that far yeah so
it has to
wow yeah so in fact
imagining this is a little bit
overwhelming so there's like a giant
like vast
icy rock thingy it's like a sphere it's
like
you know it's like it's an almost
spherical structure that engulfs
that encircles the sun and
all the long period comets come from
the oort cloud they come the way that
they appear
i mean for already i don't know hundreds
of years we've been
detecting occasionally like a comet will
come in
and it comes seemingly comes out of
nowhere
the reason these long period comets
appear
that very on very very long time scales
right
these old cloud objects that are sitting
you know 30
000 times as far away from the sun as is
the earth
actually interact with the gravity of
the galaxy the tide
effectively the tide that the galaxy
exerts upon them and their orbits slowly
change and they elongate
to the point where once they their
closest approach to the sun starts to
reach
a critical distance where ice starts to
sublimate
then we discover them as comets because
then the ice comes off of them
they look beautiful on the night sky etc
but they're all coming from
you know really really far away so is
there
are any of them coming our way from
collisions like how many collisions are
there or is there
a bunch of space for them to move around
yeah there's zero it's
completely collisionless out there the
physical radii of objects
are so small compared to the distance
between them
right it's just it is truly a
collisionless
uh environment i don't know there i
think that probably in the age
of the solar system there have literally
been zero collisions in the word cloud
wow when you like draw a picture of the
solar
system everything's really close
together so that everything i guess here
is
spaced far apart do rogue planets
like flying every once in a while and
join not rogue planets but rogue objects
from
out there oh sure i'm sure yeah join the
party
yeah absolutely uh we've seen a couple
of them um
in the last three or f or so years uh
maybe four years now
uh one the first one uh was
the one called and it's been
all over the news the second one was
comet borisov
discovered by a guy named borisov
yeah so the way you know they're coming
from elsewhere is
unlike solar system objects which travel
on elliptical paths
around the sun these guys travel on
hyperbolic paths
so they come in say hello and then
they're gone
and the fact that they exist
is totally like not surprising
right the neptune is con constantly
ejecting
kuiper belt objects into interstellar
space our solar system itself
is sort of leaking icy debris and
ejecting it so
presumably every you know planetary
systems around other stars do exactly
the same thing
you